Sona, will you hold a
parasol over my head?
[Sona] No.
My assistant said no.
(laughing)
Oh, tell her I said hello.
I like her!
Yeah, she's great.
[Sona] Oh, I love you!
Oh my god, here she comes.
[Sona] I'm a huge fan.
She's a huge fan of yours.
I'm a huge fan of yours.
I think you're so funny.
Oh my god, first I love Nailed It,
but also every time you come on the show
and you make Conan just so uncomfortable
because he's so, such a
repressed Irish Catholic.
(laughing)
It's my favorite thing.
I love you.
You're probably one of my favorite guests
that's ever been on the show.
Thank you!
What a treat!
So you love that Nicole
makes me uncomfortable
because I'm so repressed.
Yes, yes.
All right, good.
All right, I'm gonna now
socially distance from Sona.
That's why I love her.
(laughing)